5 4 3 2 1 bonne année
allez on enlève les chaussures on y va
oui allez les petits bonhommes
pour ma part
quel que soit ma place et les
circonstances
je continuerai à vous servir
et de la France notre patrie
nul ne saura déraciner mon cœur s'il
vous plaît avec les bonnes années Nouvel
An laissez moi avec ça pardon vous savez
bien que je suis pas comme ça je vous ai
jamais répondu à ça mais vous continuez
à m'envoyer des bonnes années
tout le mois de Janvier Février etc s'il
vous plaît en plus les mousselines là on
a la même conviction arrêtez avec ça
c'est des moustiques la plupart qui
m'envoient ça les frères en fait pas ça
est-ce que les compagnons ils ont fêté
le nouvel an Babou bakritique radio
c'est jusqu'à je ne sais plus quand
parce que c'est au ventes mais c'est
complet donc on a rajouté des dates
aujourd'hui au théâtre Marigny mais il
faut pas aux têtes Marigny il faut pas
appeler le matin parce que ça se trouve
il y a des places qui se libèrent pour
le soir même
qui qui non pardon on en parlera de dire
ça non non mais j'ai plein de gens qui
annule
répondez pas à des gens comme ça tous
mes vœux monsieur bonjour Paul la route
comprenez ça pourquoi on est des gens
les journalistes parce que vous
véhiculez la la bien-pensance il y en a
marre de la doxa vous comprenez ça
pour le moment on est calme mais bientôt
on va pas le rester calme je vous
demande de vous arrêter non mais parce
qu'on a le jeu soigné les Français je
vous demande de vous arrêter parce que
je dois passer un autre sujet je vais
vous laisser alors non il reste une
minute il reste une minute ben oui vous
avez pris tout le temps j'ai pris est-ce
que vous trouvez normal qu'on laisse des
Français avec du doliprane chez eux mais
c'est plus le cristaux normal c'est plus
le cas c'est plus le cas je vous en
suis plus enduit vous croyez qu'on soit
une fois les gens là
ce n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas hésité à voter Chirac que
lorsqu'il y avait le Pen en face
serai-je obligé entre Pécresse et Macron
ou entre Pécresse et les gens qu'on peut
même pas nommer
hertre Macron et les gens qu'on ne peut
même pas mouer je serais peut-être
obligé de voter Macron mais
avec beaucoup
je prends tout doucement les hommes
comme ils sont
ça coûte dû me mon âme à souffrir ce
qu'ils font
ça c'est le projet de ma vie j'y arrive
pas mais je voudrais atteindre il avait
fait un tour de France il y a quelques
temps avec son mouvement qui s'appelle
simple on l'a vu afficher derrière
c'était pour la et pour la déconfler des
complexification des normes et juste
avant il avait fait un tour notamment
d'Europe puisqu'il avait décidé d'aller
sur les traces de Montaigne avec son
cheval destinada c'était il y a à peu
près c'était en 2020 entre les deux
confinement pourquoi Montaigne car mon
frère car montagne en 1580 et ça Luc le
sait il amuse la galerie le zouave le
Zoua très bien il a voulu rejoindre
voilà rejoindre Rome et depuis Bordeaux
du cheval ou non
à propos de votre entourage Éric Zemmour
qui est Sarah Knafo
ma collaboratrice
m'accompagne
il n'y aurait pas eu de campagne sans
s'arrête la peau
votre compagne mais on s'arrêtera là
si vous me permettez c'est la première
fois que vous le dites
sérieusement ça fait 50 fois que je dis
que je m'en vais
je vous jure ça fait 55
et je reviens dans 2 minutes uniquement
pour voir comment ça se passe sans moi
vous voyez je change mes lunettes genre
en régie je voulais savoir
[ __ ] j'y vais vraiment je vous laisse
sur l'éducation nationale quand on sait
l'immense je dis bien l'immense quantité
de pièces comédie et tragédie que
Corneille a produite mais non mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce raisonnement
et qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
raisonnement mettez un échec le
Misanthrope a été un échec sont deux
chefs-d'œuvre Toto mais mais de quoi on
parle oui mais c'est parce qu'il dit
c'est pas du tout au 17e siècle c'était
qui l'auteur de le plus élevé
le mois sans alcool le mois de janvier
sans alcool auquel
le vice-président modem de l'Assemblée
Sylvain vaserman ne participe
visiblement pas c'était vendredi soir
après l'adoption d'un amendement dans le
cadre du vote du projet de loi pour le
passe vaccinal nous passons à un
amendement rédactionnel qui a un avis
favorable pour contre adopter merci
Madame Ménard le 110
alors ça le champagne exprès
et là je vois d'un coup genre une fille
qui se retourne
et j'ai mis
un truc de fou j'ai la chair en plus
on vous a découvert comme sosie de
Jean-Michel Blanquer lors de ce
happening près de près du ministère
l'éducation nationale en tout cas un
très bon dimanche
c'est votre première télé là comme ça
publiquement alors c'est ma première
télé en plateau oui oui en tant que
sosie en tant que sosie et avec un peu
de chance je vais pas rester sous ici
longtemps que ça
murène requin numéro
[Musique]
et que la petite sirène
reste mon compte de fait préféré de tous
les temps
parce que en plus à la le costard de la
sirène j'avais pas vu ça parfait parfait
quand on a travaillé on a le droit de
s'arrêter
vous en avez comme ça
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous avez dit j'ai dit
est-ce que vous en avez ça reçoit vous
en avez d'autres monsieur de La Palice
je suis sourd depuis mes données
vous avez quelque chose contre les
handicapés j'ai remarqué
une phrase de Sagan qui me rend dingue
c'est pas parce que la vie est pas
élégante qu'il faut se comporter comme
elle c'est pas mal